hey everyone and welcome to f8 we're
really glad to have you here with us
today last year we introduced a
different kind of f8 the new f8 isn't
about some big new product announcement
or changing direction it's about
bringing our whole community together to
talk about how we can help you build
grow and monetize your apps and we
focused on these themes a lot over the
last year and our developer community
has made some incredible progress we've
doubled the size of our developer
community across the whole range of
Facebook services there are now hundreds
of thousands of developers building on
Facebook's tools including more than
half outside of the US more than 30
million apps and sites have been used
have been built using Facebook's tools
last year we drove more than three and a
half billion app installs people shared
more than 50 billion pieces of content
from apps that they're using to their
friends on Facebook we paid out more
than 8 billion dollars to developers in
the last five years and more than 90%
the top hundred apps on iOS and Android
are integrated with Facebook because of
all the apps and services that you're
all building the Facebook ecosystem is
stronger than ever
so I want to take a moment to thank you
for being a part of our community and
for choosing to work with us you're the
ones who are connecting the world and
we're really proud to serve
so today I want to talk about how our
community is going to continue making
progress and I want to start with the
two major themes that we introduced at
last year's f8 the first theme is
stability because to help you build grow
and monetize your apps you need to be
able to really rely on our platform so
last year at f8 we committed to making
our platform really really stable and we
even changed our mantra from move fast
and break things to move fast with
stable in front because we recognize
that when you're operating at scale
stability is how you move quickly we
introduced it to your stability
guarantee for all of our major and core
api's we committed to fixing all major
bugs within 48 hours and I'm proud to
say that we hit both of these things we
also wanted to deal with the smaller
bugs that you report so we had an
internal goal to reduce the number of
bugs in the system by more than 66
percent and we hit that and this year we
want to go even further so starting
today we're making a new commitment to
fix more than 90% of the small bugs that
you report within 30 days and that's in
addition to the 48-hour commitment on
fixing any major bugs we're also
introducing a bug dashboard so you can
track how we're performing against this
goal and when you submit a bug you'll
know when you can expect it to get fixed
all right so we're continuing to build
on this important theme of stability for
our community all right now let's talk
about our next theme in all of our
products and our platform we want to
make sure that we always put people
first
you know what world here to serve the
people who are using our products so we
need to make sure that we always put
them first by making sure that we keep
everyone safe and by giving people more
control over their experiences because
when people feel good about their
privacy and their security that's when
they're open to trying new experiences
like all of the apps that you're all
building so here's how we're approaching
this with Facebook log in our aim is to
give people complete control over the
information that they share with apps
Facebook logon continues
be by far the most popular way that
people want to log into apps and today
more than 80% of the top hundred apps
use Facebook loggin last year at f8 we
introduced a new facebook login flow
that gives people even more control over
the information that they're sharing
with apps we created a simple review
process to make sure that developers
aren't asking for more permissions than
they really need and since making this
change apps are now requesting 50% fewer
permissions than they were before and
are seeing more than 10 percent
increases in the rate of people logging
in now over the next month more apps are
going to migrate over to the new loggin
and we think that these changes are
going to make people feel a lot more
comfortable and make the ecosystem a lot
healthier overall now another effort
that we're focused on is helping
developers protect people's security
last month we announced a new platform
called thread exchange that allows
companies to exchange information about
malware and cyberattacks malware is
getting more sophisticated and it's
increasingly challenging for any one
company or developer to keep up with all
the different threats that are out there
and we saw this firsthand last year when
there was an attack there was spreading
spam on Facebook anyone who came in
contact with it had a really bad
experience now what we investigated this
we found that the attackers
infrastructure was actually hosted on
the platforms of other technology
companies in our industry now the reason
why attackers do this is because they
assume that developers aren't
communicating and sharing with each
other so in this case we just called up
these other companies we stopped the
attack but this taught us a bigger
lesson and it's what motivated us to
create thread exchange now we're growing
this slowly but we've already heard from
thousands of developers who want to join
these are some of the folks already and
we've heard from a lot of folks who want
to join from industries as different as
health and finance and media and retail
and we're going to be adding more
developers soon so if you think you have
some security information that could
benefit the whole community let us know
all right so these are some of the ways
that we're working to create a more
stable platform and to put people first
these are the themes that we started
talking about at last year's f8 and
we're going to continue focusing on them
to serve our community better and to
help all of our developers build grow
and monetize your apps all right now
let's talk a bit about the future over
the last few years Facebook has really
evolved in our approach to how we
connect the world Facebook used to be
this single blue app and it did a lot of
different things now Facebook is a
family of apps more than 1.4 billion
people use the core Facebook app but
also more than 700 million people use
groups and 700 million use whatsapp and
600 million use messenger and more than
300 million people use Instagram every
month now we're building this family so
we can offer unique world-class
experiences for all of the ways that
people want to share because people need
to be able to express everything that
matters to them with all of the
different groups of people that they
care about this is how we give people
the power to share and to make the world
more open and connected now there are so
many more ways that people want to share
that this family is just going to keep
on growing but it's important to keep
this shift in mind because moving from
just being a single service to a family
of world-class apps for helping people
share in different ways is the biggest
shift that we've made in our strategy of
helping to connect people in many years
now this also reflects the fact that the
content that people want to share is
changing too over time that there's this
really clear trend that technology gives
us tools for sharing richer and richer
content with an increasing and
increasing frequency so if you look back
at Facebook five years ago most of the
content that people shared was text
all right status updates and wall posts
now today it's photos another visual
content if you fast-forward five years
it's going to be video and if you look
out even further beyond that it's
probably going to be even more immersive
content like VR and air now at the same
time as we're seeing this trend towards
increasing richness of content we're
also seeing that the frequency of
sharing is increasing you know now
everyone has messaging apps and groups
apps on their phones that allow us to
constantly stay connected with all the
people that we care about and share many
more times each day than we've been able
to in the past so this is a really big
opportunity but we can't do it alone
because all of the different things that
people want to share are happening in
all of the different apps that you're
building so in order to keep up with
this future where people are gonna want
to share all these new kinds of content
we need to be able to build tools for
you to enable people to share all the
different kinds of content that they're
producing with all the people they care
about so we're going to go about doing
this by preparing for a future where
they're gonna be all different kinds of
content that people want to share to all
different kinds of people so let's get
started today by I want to show you
something kind of fun it's it's a bit
futuristic but it's an example of the
kind of content that we expect to see in
the system over time so right now we're
at this interesting transition where
we're starting to see traditional video
blend with even more immersive content
now when you think about virtual reality
a lot of people first think about gaming
but I actually think that video is going
to be even more engaging in a lot of
ways so these are our spherical videos
you can move around within it and you
can change your viewing angle and that's
possible because the videos are filmed
on up to 24 different cameras at once
now this is a new and much more
immersive type of content it's not
something that you just consume
passively you're actually interacting
with it and you feel like you're there
so soon we're going to start supporting
spherical videos and news feed people
already watched more than
three billion videos a day and newsfeed
and it's some of the most engaging
content in our system we're going to
bring spherical videos to oculus to
you're going to be able to put on your
headset and just feel like you're really
there so we're actually experimenting
with live spherical video here today we
have a spherical camera filming at our
headquarters down in Menlo Park so after
the session is done um you can head over
to our humorously and ironically named
teleportation station to get a sense of
what our crew down at Facebook
headquarters feels about FA all right so
now moving on continuing this theme of
all of these different kinds of content
that we want to enable people to share
but moving to something that's a little
bit more in the present the next thing
we want to do has make it easier for
people to share all of the different
kinds of content that they're creating
in your apps with all of the different
people that care about the whole
Facebook family of apps so we're going
to simplify our interfaces for sharing
from apps to Facebook family now today
there are actually more than a dozen
different ways that you can share from
an app into Facebook and that's because
you know they're all these different
interfaces on iOS and Android and
Windows Phone and mobile web and desktop
now what all these different versions
mean is that whatever the best version
is is not what everyone is using today
and we've heard this feedback very
clearly from everyone in our community
and our developers that they want us to
fix this because people want to be able
to share into messages right people want
to be able to share into groups people
never want to be surprised by what their
content is going to look like when they
share it so today we're going to fix
this we're introducing an elegant and
consistent way to share from all of the
different apps that you're building
across the whole family of different
Facebook services so the new share sheet
creates a consistent experience for
everyone using apps to share with anyone
they want including in messenger in
groups so if you want to share that run
that you made
with just a few people instead of all of
your friends on Facebook or Instagram
now you can do that
in exactly the same way that you would
have previously shared into a feed so
this is just the first step towards
creating better sharing experiences
across this whole family of apps and
we're gonna have a lot more to talk
about in this vein over the coming few
months all right now the last area that
I want to talk about is focusing on
building platforms across our whole
family of apps now one of the
fastest-growing and most important
members of our family is messenger we
launched messenger about four years ago
and now more than 600 million people are
using messenger to communicate every
month and as messenger has grown we
think that this service has the
potential to help people express
themselves in new ways to connect
hundreds of millions of new people and
to become a really important
communication tool for the world so over
the last couple of years we've been
building messenger into a service that
can help you express yourself and many
more ways beyond just simple text
messages we added basic staples like
photos and video we added stickers to
help people easily express any emotion
we added location so that you can easily
tell your friends where you are we added
voice calling recently and now already
messenger accounts for more than 10
percent of mobile VoIP calling globally
and it's growing really quickly and we
just started rolling out payments and
that was just last week so we're
continuing to develop new things we have
a lot more planned in the months ahead
but until now we've focused on improving
messenger by building all these features
ourselves so today we're going to talk
about the next step in our messenger
strategy today we're introducing
messenger platform it's a new platform
that developers
it's a messenger platform is a new
platform that developers can use to
build apps that help people connect with
the more than 600 million people who are
using messenger as the communicate every
day so by opening up Messenger is a
platform we're going to be able to
express help people express themselves
and rich new ways and make their
conversations better so now they're
going to be a lot of things that we can
do with messenger platform over time but
this is a really exciting big new area
and opportunity but we want to start
small in focus today so we're going to
talk about two things and the first is
giving people more tools for expression
I'm going to show you quickly how this
works so we're extending the composer
and messenger so now you're going to be
able to easily inline find different
services that help you say anything you
want better and you're going to build to
discover these services right in line
and they're going to deep link right to
the App Store so that you can download
them very easily and you can create
content you can share directly into
messenger and what you're going to see
is that your friends are going to be
easy easily able to reply and install
the apps that you're sharing with them
so here's an example of just a really
quick video that we made right before
this with with an app called JibJab I
sent this to our developer team who's
working on Facebook platform
congratulating them on shipping this and
yeah it's simple it's fun it's easy all
right so we're really excited about what
about the new kinds of things and
creative tools that we're going to be
able to enable with with messenger
platform and you know there's a lot more
to do here but we're really excited to
seeing to see what you're all gonna be
able to do even with these fast and
simple tools that we're rolling out
first all right now the second thing
that we want to talk about is making
messenger a place where you can easily
communicate with the businesses you care
about in addition to the people you care
about so currently if you want to get in
touch with a business you know most of
us probably
still calling but you know I don't have
to know anyone who likes calling
businesses right I mean it's just not
fast or convenient and it definitely
doesn't feel like the future so you know
think about how useful it would be if
you could just message a business and
instantly get information about whatever
you need make a reservation by something
in line change chip shipping information
in times so today we're introducing a
way for you to communicate with
businesses right through messenger and
we think that the key to making this
experience good is starting these
conversations at the right time so for
example right after you purchase
something online if you need to change
your order you're gonna be able to do
that right and messenger you're going to
receive a receipt as well as shipping
information you can track your package
helping people communicate more
naturally with businesses is going to
improve I think almost every person's
life because it's something that
everyone does so really excited to see
how people start to use this some
businesses start to use this when we
start rolling it out pretty soon now
already working with a small set of
partners on this and this is something
that David is going to talk about along
with the rest of messenger platform in
just a moment
all right so those are just a few of the
things that were focused on for
developers as we think about the future
of sharing and for the rest of this talk
today we're going to focus on all the
ways that you can use the Facebook
family to build grow and monetize your
apps